bundesinnenminister horst seehofer hat
die todesfahrt von münster bei einem
besuch des tatortes als feiges und
brutales verbrechen verurteilt
gemeinsam mit dem nordrhein
westfälischen ministerpräsidenten armin
laschet und innenminister herbert reul
gedachte er am sonntag vor dem gasthaus
großer kiepenkerl der toten polizei und
rettungskräften dankte er für ihre
schnelle und professionelle arbeit mehr
klarheit über das tatmotiv konnte der
bundesinnenminister zunächst allerdings
nicht schaffen es gebe starke hinweise
dass es sich um einen einzeltäter
handele und kein bezug zur terrorszene
bestehe
die sicherheitslage in deutschland seit
dennoch angespannt sagte seehofer extrem
angespannt so sieht das muss man immer
wieder sagen aber tun auch was
polizeipräsenz und all diese cent
schauen sie daraus streifenwagen
praktische pflege
dann hätte schon alles andere sei
möglicherweise abgelaufen für die
polizei eine präsent gewesen
im anschluss gab polizeipräsident hans
joachim kulisch einen kurzen einblick in
die bisherigen ermittlungen wir haben
seit gestern nachmittag in der ganzen
nacht die wohnungen des täters
durchsucht sie werden verstehen bei vier
wohnungen zwei davon in ostdeutschland 2
in münster können wir jetzt nicht
abschließend sagen dass wir da gar
nichts finden würden aber die erste doch
schon etwas intensivere durchsicht hat
keinerlei hinweise auf einen politischen
hintergrund der geben
das ist wie gesagt ein vorläufiger stand
kulisch äußerte sich nicht dazu
weshalb der täter vier wohnungen hatte
derartige sachverhalte seien aber bei
diesem täterprofil nicht ungewöhnlich
und müssten nicht unbedingt auf einen
kriminellen hintergrund hindeuten